cases of covert 19 are rising in russia
with infection rates returning to winter
levels and death tolls at a record high
despite the vaccine being available
since december only 14 percent of the
population
has had two shots mistrust of the state
and its medical system
are partly to blame authorities who've
been accused of mixed messages are now
scrambling to contain the surge
over the last week we registered a new
record of the number of hospitalizations
people in intensive care units and
people dead from covet
therefore we took a number of decisions
on restrictive measures
linked in particular to the mandatory
vaccination of service workers
the kremlin is using incentives to get
people vaccinated
in one region free tickets to the circus
for those who get the jab
no entry to bars and restaurants for
those who do not
a strict qr code system requires
customers to provide
proof of vaccination or have a negative
pcr test to eat indoors
but many are unhappy
i don't like it what's the point of it
it's restricting people from visiting
cafes the vaccine as you know will not
save you from the disease
maybe you get less sick but there's no
point in this it's making
vaccination mandatory that's all and
it's another setback for a hospitality
industry already suffering
there are no other options the only
surprise is that people do not need qr
codes in public transport
fitness clubs and beauty salons or
shopping centers
but i guess it's just a matter of time
[Music]
a small number protesting against the
inoculation drive
fearful that the sputnik vaccine has
still not been approved by the world
health organization
and angry that those who refuse it will
be shut out of parts of society
on tuesday scientists admitted their
sputnik vaccine
is slightly less effective against the
delta variant than originally reported
while the government announced it won't
be able to vaccinate 60 percent of its
population by autumn
as planned charlie angela al jazeera